my connection to the sea started when I
was little I spend most of my summers at
the sea swimming school King
ever since I was two and a half years
old I started swimming I kept on
developing love for the water the water
hearing where our skin is different from
anywhere else as a Slovenian I feel like
water is the part of my DNA the part of
the country where I'm from is surrounded
by lakes and rivers and waterfalls and
there's something so healing about water
I love I love the sound of it it kind of
puts me into a meditative place despite
being so small Slovenia really holds
high biodiversity but also diversity of
dermatological forms and also types of
water we have this lively Alpine rivers
flowing down the mountains and meeting
the seeded Radek sea and bringing game
nutrients minerals that support high
productivity and diversity this place is
special because it's like a perfect
union of many nature's very
contemplative and good for humans and
animals and plants living here you would
not think at first side but also the mud
here is good for us putting it on
feeling how it works in the skin it's
amazing the same way as the landscape
the land and the waters change among the
Slovenian coast so five minutes from
place to place what can be completely
different
Lake Bowen is really special it's the
biggest permanent lake in Slovenia and
it's also a lot quieter than the other
lakes which makes it not much nicer to
be in what makes me most happy though is
that this beautiful nature is only an
hour away from our very busy city in
Ljubljana so that makes it extra special
one of the things I love the most is how
I can fill my water bottle up whether
it's opening tap water or going by the
mountain where there's a water source
waters in Slovenia tastes different
wherever you go and one such area is Roe
Gasca where water is full of magnesium
and it's very beneficial for your health
so we know we have two waters which are
very special because their mineral
drinking waters all other waters are
thermal mineral waters which are used
for varnel therapies but here the burner
therapy means drinking doughnut mg
mineral water has been attracting people
here for centuries because it is the
mineral water with the highest content
of magnesium no other water in the world
has more than 1,000 exactly 1014
milligram
Museum in one meter comes from deep
underground in arambula Beijing they
call it black gold because high
concentration of healing substances and
it has beneficial effects on health I
prescribe patients a program in the
morning patients might have a betting in
water and in the afternoon they can have
much treatment one of my favorite places
to escape to is a very magical natural
pool surrounded by beautiful waterfalls
but I'm not going to tell you exactly
where that is
you're gonna have to come and discover
it yourself
[Music]